Twitter has been on a roller coaster
throughout 2022 ending on October 27th
in one of the biggest Tech takeovers in
history going back earlier this year
here in April Elon Musk made a massive
44 billion dollar bid for the company
but just three months later he called it
off Twitter sued musk sued back oh yeah
Twitter
[Laughter]
[Applause]
then he changed his mind again this has
been a drawn out fight between Twitter
and musk with a lot of twists and turns
those twists and turns take place on a
timeline that has not only influenced
stock prices but has also shown
uncertainty among employees and as
Twitter says contributed to a one
percent decline in Revenue
so how did musk's flip-flopping on the
deal lead to a six-month battle that
threw off Twitter's business his tweets
statements and text messages as well as
court documents tell the story
the timeline Starts Here on January 31st
when musk started buying up shares of
Twitter and he started sharing his
opinions about how the platform works
he did toss out a lot of ideas on how to
change Twitter how he thought he could
make Twitter better things like
emphasizing Free Speech things like
changing how it approaches content
moderation after months of buying musk
publicly disclosed a 9.2 percent stake
in the company his first tweet of the
day said simply
the next day Twitter announced that musk
would be joining the board musk is one
of the most prominent users of Twitter
but he's also been one of its loudest
critics Twitter invited him to join the
board to try to bring him into the fold
and work with him on these issues musk
tweeted that he was looking forward to
making significant improvements to
Twitter in the coming months at first
when he was talking with Twitter's
leadership it was pretty friendly but
then friction tension started to emerge
as musk was gearing up to join he was
still criticizing the platform tweeting
is Twitter dying
CEO Prague agrawal texted musk it's my
responsibility to tell you that it's not
helping me make Twitter better in the
current context twitch musk responded
I'm not joining the board this is a
waste of time we'll make an offer to
take Twitter private musk would be the
new owner and I think the thinking is
that if Twitter's private he would be
able to take more risk in trying to
overhaul or jump start their business it
didn't take long for musk to act on that
promise formally announcing his 43
billion dollar bid to take over the
company the number was later revised to
44 billion in an interview with Ted that
day he explained his decision my strong
intuitive sense is that having a public
platform that is maximally trusted
and and and broadly inclusive
is extremely important to the future of
civilization on April 25th muskin
Twitter officially reached a merger
agreement but even as musk was lining up
fresh financing and sharing more ideas
for the platform he had a surprise in
store the Billionaire's CEO announcing
just hours ago that the 44 billion
dollar deal to take Twitter private is
now on hold musk tweeted that the deal
was temporarily on hold as he was
waiting for more information from
Twitter on the number of spam accounts
on the site we know that musk had talked
about Bots before the deal
but then he started having more concerns
or saying he had more concerns and he
started questioning kind of the the
health of Twitter's business musk
expressed interest in a lower price for
the company at the all-in summit on May
16th you can't pay the same price for
something that is much worse than they
claimed Twitter's CEO addressed musk's
bot claims tweeting in a thread that the
company estimated that less than five
percent of reported monetizable daily
active users are spam accounts and they
don't believe this specific f estimation
can be performed externally musk replied
with several tweets but one was just
musk continued to push himself further
from the deal threatening to walk away
in a letter to Twitter saying he
believed the company is actively
resisting and thwarting his information
rights
musk's reversal was followed by a flurry
of coverage and commentary I feel like
Elon is pretty close to saying I'm so
sorry my two-year-old took my iPad and
clicked buy so I don't know what
so we're cool we're cool right he
officially tried to call the whole thing
off at the beginning of July I mean at
the start musk was really pushing for
this deal and Twitter was kind of
resisting and then it kind of seemed
like their positions changed and musk
was the one trying to back out well
Twitter was saying that they wanted to
close four days later Twitter formally
sued musk in an effort to force the
merger through so Twitter said they did
share information about how they handled
spam and fake accounts with musk but
musk kept demanding more and that was a
big part of the legal fight that was
going on filing took aim at musk's
flip-flopping focusing on how it
affected the company just looking
through the filing here it says quote
musk apparently believes that he unlike
every other party is subject to Delaware
contract law is free to change his mind
trash the company disrupt its operations
destroy stockholder value and walk away
musk filed a countersuit claiming
revisions to user number members in the
company's first quarter earnings in
April were what sparked his push for bot
data Twitter rejected musk's claims as
both sides prepared for a fight in court
a former Twitter employee filed a
whistleblower complaint against the
company alleging among other things the
Twitter doesn't properly count spam
accounts musk seized on that as further
ammunition to call the agreement off
but after pushing for months to end the
deal
he changed his mind again at the
beginning of October he proposed closing
on the original terms that was
surprising because it's not really like
him to back down I mean we've seen prior
lawsuits where he's fought more and for
longer in a Tesla earnings call on
October 19th musk spoke briefly about
the deal although obviously herself and
the other investors are obviously
overpaying for Twitter right now
um the long-term potential for Twitter
in my view is the order of magnitude
greater than this card value Twitter
isn't in the shape it was back in April
we have more you know economic concerns
just broadly in the economy and then
specifically for Twitter the uncertainty
has weighed on Twitter because no one
knew if the deal was actually going to
go through
upon completing the Takeover musk fired
CEO parag Agarwal and Chief Financial
Officer Ned Segal according to people
familiar with the matter Twitter did not
immediately respond to requests for
comment